hey everyone it's Mike bottles from
Oracle's calm and I'm shooting this
quick video to let you know about a
webinar that I'm doing on Wednesday
November 8th with investor inspiration
and what I'll be talking about is how
institutions use algos to camouflage
their training again this is on
Wednesday November 8th and I start at
10:00 a.m. I go for about 45 minutes I'm
kicking it off there's about 6 speakers
now brief disclaimer this presentation
is for educational informational
purposes only should not be considered a
solicitation to buy or sell a futures
contract or making it a type of
investment decision futures train
contains cancer risk is not for every
investor the investor could potentially
lose all are more than the initial
investment risk capitals might be lost
without jeopardizing one's financial
security or lifestyle only risk capital
tributes for training and only those
were sufficient risk capital should
consider trading past forints is not
necessarily indicative of future results
now you know I like this terminal is an
arms race going on in the financial
world oh no no no disrespect to the
people in the military but you know it's
a great analogy because you know there's
just race by the banks and the lesser
extent hedge funds the highly
capitalized hedge funds but more more
with the banks is to build more reliable
and faster execution platforms as well
as more comprehensive and accurate
prediction models and what do I mean
well you know one thing you probably
never thought of or cared about is how
big traders try to hide their intentions
while getting into or out of the market
that's part of the arms race and you
know all these banks right now even
though they've been cutting back on the
training side the departments of the
banks that have been getting basically
the blank checks since the you know over
the last ten years has been the IT
departments in the respect of building
out algos now why do they do that one is
because you know they've cut back on
their trading due to regulations and the
way they're trying to make it up is
through prime brokerage and offering to
clients you know all these execution out
goes so that they could beat alpha with
their you know with their executions
their fills on their trades and most
traders are familiar with iceberg orders
you know that's sort of like a basic
execution algo you know basically it
hides the size you got a five hundred
Lots to buy the iceberg at you show five
so it just keeps reloading five but
there are many many more algorithmic
trading order types such as the you app
t webview app is volume way
which price t lap time weighted average
price participate you know it's like
some people some banks call it
percentage of volume POV so you know
it's a you know every time the market
range right you want to participate you
don't want the market to start moving
and you're not participating so say you
said participate are percentage of
volume at you know fifteen percent so it
trains 100 Lots
it's a Lewis says trade fifty percent it
trades 15 Lots target closed you know
the way these markets close futures
markets you know they just stopped right
there's no closing auction in many
markets so what people are trying to do
right a lot of these index funds you
know they're trying to because they
benchmark it on the closing price so
they're trying to get as close to the
closing price as possible say they got
500 last time I you can't just boom 500
Lots right at you know 59 and 59 seconds
no you're gonna sort of paints it out
steps momentum value hunts hunt is an
interesting one you know it's sort of
you know some place is called ghost
orders you know you it's waiting for
size to come in so say you want to buy
like you know five hundred Lots up to a
certain price of you know forty nine so
if offers come in at 47 at forty eight
or even forty nine you know it'll lift
them but not the whole the whole thing
is it'll say you know don't buy more
than fifty percent so if there's 20 Lots
there it'll buy ten Lots things like
that implementation shortfall and other
junk and I get a whole presentation on
all those different types of algos but
that's not what this point is it's
basically all these dago's are created
to hide the traders intents and
commitments to the market right they
don't want to just go in and both right
through the markets right I mean
depending on how old you are if you're
familiar you know when there was trading
floors existed you know you used to be
able to call the floor say you know
who's buying who's telling I'll say ah
Solomon's buying or NatWest is selling
and you can sort of make your decisions
from there if you knew you know who
traded through what house you know you
know like Soros would trade through a
certain company Tudor would trade
through a certain company and if you
knew that you could sort of dis certain
you know you wouldn't know for sure you
just be making an educated guess
at best but you know you don't have that
because with electronic trading it's all
anonymous and you don't know who's on
the other side of your trade but one
thing is certain if it's traded in the
market it will show up in the order flow
and from the order flow if you know what
to look for you can have an insight you
know how strong a move
really may be so what I'll be talking
about on this presentation on Wednesday
is how banks either trading activity but
how you can see that activity in the
order flow now you know I know Peter
Davies is going to be speaking and
honestly I own jigsaw okay you know full
disclosure I mean it's a great tool
I sort of liken it to having a slot
machine on your trading desk but you
know for people that don't know how to
use it sometimes they get caught up in
icebergs and I'll be honest with you you
know I've been using icebergs I've been
trading electronically since the 90s
when it first started that's why I left
the trading floor and the seeing me is
because that was at the time when global
was just starting up and you know the
firm that I was with was saying hey you
know we need some people to go trade at
night on Globex oh I ain't sure you know
I'm in my early 20s I'm into computers
sure I'll do it so you know I've been
trading the icebergs were really really
introduced when was that when globe x2
started up I think that was in 97 I was
on geo in 96 or 97 you know then the
next version of globe X that you could
do it and but I believe it was also
available on available on 9 X + 9 X
access and project day which is the old
cbot one you know basically you could
hide your size but you know people that
talk to it with domes a lot you hear
that term icebergs icebergs and there's
there's times where icebergs are
important but most of the time you know
most people that have size of over 50
watts are generally going to iceberg it
anyway so sometimes you know people are
looking for icebergs when majority of
the hoarders in the market are already
icebergs but you know I'm gonna try and
show you how
well maybe you can discern some of the
other types of order types that are out
there that people can use and how to
identify institutional algorithmic
trading in order flow again you know
icebergs is a prime example I mean you
all you've seen it if you've ever
watched the market I mean let
you know if you watch the bid offer you
can see size being replaced in there you
know that's it that's a basic that's an
iceberg pipe but you know if you're not
watching it you know like a hawk you
know you want to be able to pick up
these things and you know lastly how to
trade alongside the institution logos
and again I'm not saying that you know
the institutions know everything you
know if the institutions do everything
then you know they did just be making
money hand over fist they would never
ever need a government bailout or
anything but the fact is you know
institutions also lose money but in
general they are on the right side and
as a trader as an intraday trader you
really just want to get in and get out
you know get in for the the ride and get
out when the ride is over
right again I'm not saying you know
trade you know long side institutions
and you know oh they're because they're
buying it today and again now three
months from now no you know they're
buying it now for whatever reason okay I
want to buy now and as soon as they're
behind is is over I want to get out so
you know those are those are the three
topics I'll be talking about I think
it's going to be very informative for
people I've never really delved that
much into this these topics and again
you know this is a very interesting
topic because I know firsthand right I
was part of the involvement I didn't I'm
not a coder right I'm a trader I traded
at JP Morgan but I worked with the guys
and they would ask me you know for my
feedback on hey how can we make this
algo better what would you like to see
in an algo I'm not the inventor of these
algos no but I've used them so I know
their purposes I know how they're used
to hide orders I mean really that's why
they're invented you know and there's
there's companies no taxes the no taxes
it's one of those companies it's hard
for me to pronounce you know the French
company that's the whole business model
is to build these algos for people so
again you know I think it'd be very
informative if you can't attend live
don't worry as long as you sign up
you'll receive access to recordings you
don't need to email me just sign up for
it you may go to order flows com click
sign up and it'll take you right to the
sign up page I'll take you to a landing
page and you go sign up or excuse me
or you could go to the link below in the
description which is the actual
investor inspiration link so again yeah
I hope to see you there on Wednesday
November 8th but again you know if you
can't attend I realize I'm doing this at
10 a.m. Eastern time and you know people
got to work and whatever take the kids
to school that's fine just sign up at
least you get access to the recording
when it's available so thanks everyone
and I hope to see you there on Wednesday
if not you know sign up for it and at
least you can get access to the
recording so thanks everyone have a
great day bye bye